so you got all this space here okay so
bait him up to go back Baseline yeah
because it's wide open okay all right
yeah and don't if you if you want to try
to hit go through it boom I'm here
I know but right do it don't look for
the call okay but if you got him that
high that means you got the Baseline all
right keep going
we got two minutes left don't play with
the game don't play with the game come
on
that's an angry veteran in his 15 years
has seen a lot of crazy things at the
end of games
this is a 101st playoff game of Jeff
Green he's played 15 years with 11
different teams not bad for a guy in his
fifth year at open heart surgery and he
wants to play into his 40s he's 36 now
says he's not ready by any means to
think about retirement and he's been a
terrific veteran leader for this nuggets
team
but that's an example of leadership
responsibility accountability and
experience